now to washington in those stunning
accusations from a former facebook
employee who spoke with 60 minutes
francis haugen will testify to the
senate about internal company data
showing potentially dangerous
consequences from facebook's recent
actions chris van cleave reports from
capitol hill
ahead of her testimony this morning
former facebook employee francis haugen
and her legal team filed at least eight
complaints with the security and
exchange commission obtained by cbs news
from a congressional source there were
conflicts of interest
between what was good for the public
and what was good for facebook
and facebook over and over again chose
to optimize for its own interests like
making more money she'll testify before
the senate urging stronger regulation
and claiming facebook became a dollar
company by paying for its profits with
our safety including the safety of our
children haugen told 60 minute scott
pelly facebook needs a complete reboot
and ceo mark zuckerberg needs to take
action we can't start from the place of
we have a problem we need to declare
moral bankruptcy you know we need it we
need to put it on the table we need to
admit what we've done and then we need
to work from there to making something
better moral bankruptcy yeah moral
bankruptcy is an opportunity for mark
for facebook to come in and say
we completely messed up we have to
reorganize the company i agree
completely
so far we've seen no acknowledgement
no accountability no commitment to
disclose everything in their files
no
agreement that there have to be reforms
that is
in effect moral bankruptcy in my view
senator richard blumenthal will chair
the hearing he expects bipartisan
outrage over reports facebook hid the
potential risks of suicide and negative
body image its instagram platform may
pose to children and teens i think that
what we're seeing
is
big tech's big tobacco moment what we're
seeing here is facebook through
instagram
confronting how its own greed
is putting kids at risk and that's a big
tobacco moment
facebook tells cbs news every day our
teams have to balance protecting the
ability of billions of people to express
themselves openly with the need to keep
our platform a safe and positive place
we continue to make significant
improvements to tackle the spread of
misinformation and harmful content
senator blumenthal believes regulations
will be necessary and that could include
legal liability for platforms for
content posted on their sites and apps
tony
chris thank you very much